muy bien veamos si podemos encontrar la
integral indefinida de 1 entre 5 x
cuadrado menos 30 x más 65 de x pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrarla
muy bien esto será interesante y un poco
peliaguda primero vamos a trabajar a la
juntos podría ser que inmediatamente
intentes usar varias técnicas de
integración y encuentres muchos
obstáculos es por eso que en este
denominador intentaremos completar el
cuadrado perfecto una vez que
completemos el cuadrado llegaremos a una
integral que tendrá la forma de la
derivada del arco tangente si esto te
sirve de pista entonces de nuevo pausa
el vídeo y trata de continuar con la
solución
ok vamos a resolverlo juntos esta vez
intentaré simplificar un poco nuestro
denominador para que el coeficiente de
mi x cuadrada sea 1 para eso puedo
factorizar un 5 en mi denominador si
hago esto entonces esta integral me
quedara como un quinto por la integral
indefinida de 1 entre y ojo estoy factor
izando un 5 en el denominador entonces
me quedo con x cuadrada menos 6 x + 3 cm
de x
ahora como mencioné voy a completar el
cuadrado perfecto por acá abajo déjame
escribirlo tengo un quinto por la
integral indefinida de 1 / x 4 a adam
menos 6x y como puedes observar no
tenemos un cuadrado perfecto en la forma
en la que lo escribimos entonces
escribiremos este más 13 hasta el final
y ahora completar el cuadrado cuál es el
número que debo de sumar y después de
restar recuerda no queremos cambiar el
valor del denominador para poder tener
en esta parte un cuadrado perfecto bueno
esto lo hemos hecho antes si tomamos el
coeficiente de la x elevada a la primera
potencia lo cual es menos 3 y después lo
elevamos al cuadrado
así que sumamos 9 pero si sumas un 9
también debes de restarle por lo tanto
de esta parte de aquí de ésta
obtendremos x menos 3 elevado al
cuadrado y de esta otra parte obtendré
4 - 93 cm es 4 y por supuesto no
olvidemos nuestra de x al final ahora
déjame reescribir la de esta manera
tengo un quinto por la integral
indefinida de 1 / x 3 al cuadrado más 4
y de hecho también podemos ver al 4 como
2 al cuadrado es más déjame escribirlas
y 2 al cuadrado de x ahora seguramente
muchos de ustedes dirán oye esto se
parece mucho a un arco tangente pero voy
a intentar simplificar aún más para que
sea verdaderamente claro que tenemos
involucrado un arco tangente y para ello
haré una sustitución y primero vamos a
factorizar un 4 en nuestro denominador
si hacemos eso tendremos que un quinto
por un cuarto hat fuera de la integral
lo cual será un veinteavo un veinteavo
por la integral de
/ x 3 al cuadrado entre 2 al cuadrado
que es 4 + 1
y claro no olvidemos el final a de x y
ahora podemos escribir esto como e
intento hacerlo paso por paso aunque
muchos de ustedes puedan hacer esto de
una manera más rápida tenemos uno entre
20 un veinteavo por la integral
indefinida de uno entre x menos 3 entre
2 esto elevado al cuadrado más uno de x
y ahora si la sustitución 1 es muy clara
voy a hacer la sustitución un igual a x
menos 3 entre 2 o podemos ponerlo como
un medio de x menos 3 medios
esto es x menos 3 entre 2 y ahora de 1
es igual a un medio d
ahora lo queremos es reescribir un poco
esta integral para que aparezca el un
medio en el numerador por lo tanto si
hago esto voy a poner aquí un médium y
entonces estoy multiplicando afuera de
la integral por 2 es decir multiplicó
por 2 y dividido por 2 es una forma de
verlo y por lo tanto afuera me quedara
un décimo y si ahora hago mi sustitución
1 pondré un décimo por la integración
definida de y observar tengo un médium
de x justo aquí que de hecho es de 1 y
bueno puedo ponerlo en el numerador o al
final y después tengo uno entre y aquí
abajo tendré en mi denominador o
cuadrada más 1 e inmediatamente podrás
reconocer esto cuál es la derivada del
arco tangente de un bueno justo será 1 /
cuadrada + 1 por lo tanto esto será un
décimo del arco tangente de un y por
supuesto
olvidar sumar la constante cm porque
estamos tomando la integral indefinida
por último tenemos que regresar a
nuestra variable original hacer la
sustitución de reversa recuerda sabemos
que uno es igual a un medio de x menos
tres medios por lo tanto con un pequeño
redoble de tambor podemos dar la
respuesta final esto será un décimo por
el arco tangente de un pero es igual a x
menos 3 entre 2 que también lo hemos
escrito de esta manera como un medio de
x menos tres medios y entonces me quedan
el arco tangente de x menos tres entre
dos más c y ya está lo hemos logrado nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo